as a scientist and a theorist i
frequently encounter people who will
tell me that uh you know they will say
with a a
glimmer in their eye that the plural of
anecdote is not data right now
i also know that at some level the word
anecdote is
misused by people it's mu it's used
effectively
to
dismiss a piece of evidence rather than
allow it to be integrated at a natural
level and it is certainly the case that
a single anecdote is not a pattern in
and of itself
but it is a kind of evidence and the
trick the way one figures out whether
there is a pattern does initially
involve looking at anecdotes you can't
look at data because data only exists
after you have set out to collect it
what causes you to set out to collect it
are
uh patterns that one informally notices
which actually are the first step in the
scientific method observation
involves looking at patterns and saying
i wonder why this is true
here's a possible explanation and if
this possible explanation was correct
these other things repeat would be true
and then i can go look for those other
things and see if they are in fact
present right observation hypothesis
prediction test that's the method
so when people say
they roll their eyes at the idea that an
anecdote has caught your attention what
they are really doing is interrupting
the first step in the scientific method
and i would point out that yes it is
true that it is preferable
when one has anecdotes that are
suggestive of a pattern right anecdotes
say people collected in a facebook group
reporting symptoms that are not
identical but are suggestive of some
sort of underlying pathology that that
should cause
rigorous tests to be done
that's what one wants to happen
but when there is resistance to running
those tests when there is resistance to
analyzing the evidence that has
accumulated then we are left with the
anecdotes not by choice but that's
simply what is present for us to
evaluate and so there's something
i would say diabolical
about
claiming that something is safe
and then ignoring evidence that it might
not be so safe and then chastising those
who are looking at the evidence that
exists the anecdotes and saying you
don't have a right to do that because
anecdotes aren't science right that's
all nonsense
have i misdescribed any of this oh i
think i think that's accurate i mean i
think it was charles sanders purse who
said do not block the course of inquiry
and um that's that's what's happening
here is the course of inquiries being
blocked actually there have been quite a
number of published case
studies and so this is interesting
because high level medical journals do
publish single case studies or a case
study of three individuals or seven
individuals or that kind of thing i
could send you
links to published case studies of
apparent
you know severe adverse events after
these covet vaccines some of them
neurological in nature um so it isn't
even true to say that no respectable
journal will publish something except
for a large you know
blinded trial or something like that
that's not true they publish case
studies all the time and then after the
case studies come in then they might go
out and gather more um another thing
that i would want to mention would be
that testimony is always going to be
important
um even if a scientist does a study
you're going to be dependent on the
scientist's testimony that i mean if he
he could lie there is such a thing as
scientific fraud so
ultimately we're going to be dependent
on testimony unless you want to get
deeper down to you know sense data or
something really underlying but uh you
know testimonies at a pretty fundamental
level epistemologically um moreover when
you do
even larger scientific studies you're
going to be using to some extent
anecdotal information as far as like
does the patient say that this symptom
has resolved i've been reading a lot
more scientific papers than i ever you
know had before medical papers in
researching this and you'll find you
know the researchers will say okay that
um the patient said
that they had experienced such and such
such and such many patients said they
experienced such such degree of
resolution in their pain
for whatever whatever the medication
might be to find out if a medication is
effective so they're taking that the
word for it of those patients and
recording it so in that sense anecdotes
are feeding into scientific
investigation even the most formal kind
of scientific investigation at multiple
different levels yes it's absolutely
maddening to me as somebody who
practices science that we would dismiss
anecdote right if i don't have
those anecdotal patterns to work from in
order to figure out what hypothesis
might be worth testing
then there's no way to start and
it occurs to me even just talking to you
right now that we have
medicine functioning at different levels
right we have public health and we have
you know
official guidance on what drugs work on
which conditions and things like this
but the practice of medicine that takes
place in a doctor's office is in fact
supposed to be about the doctor's
ability to work from anecdote and figure
out what it suggests about what you
likely have
what things tend to work for people who
have similar types of diseases doctors
are actually supposed to test hypotheses
at a level that isn't formal
right they're supposed to say well gee
that sounds like you might have a
problem a generalized inflammation
problem if they're a good doctor they
might say let's figure out what's
causing the inflammation a regular
doctor might say let's treat the
inflammation you know
but in any case the point is doctors are
not running studies on
large numbers of patients in general
they are working with
individuals whose presentation is um
individual in it by its very nature
and when they do it right they end up
alleviating symptoms and treating
disorders in a in a way that's effective
so
at some level i feel like we are being
um
we are being fed
epistemological nonsense so that we will
not be able to recognize a pattern that
is obvious in front of us yes well and
the doctor himself might then use
induction uh you know doctors will say
to me i had a patient who you know i
don't know how many times you've heard a
doctor say that oh yeah i've had
patients who i had a patient who and so
then that will lead a doctor to maybe
use a medication more often because it's
worked on his patients so doctors are
doing informal science like that all the
time and just in their own practices
absolutely and i would also you know i i
think i mentioned it earlier but
we also have
systems set up so that we are not left
with anecdotal evidence we have the
vares system in the u.s for example
which is supposed to capture adverse
events following vaccination and should
there be a pattern it doesn't mean that
every instance that shows up in the very
system will be caused by a vaccine but
if we simply record every time somebody
has had a
serious medical incident in close
proximity to a vaccination event if we
collect all of that evidence we'll be
able to say hey look if there is nothing
with these vaccines
then the rate at which people have let's
say a heart attack following this
vaccination shouldn't be any different
than the rate at which they have a heart
attack following
the flu vaccine and if the rate is
10 times 50 times higher then you say
well huh i wonder why these two groups
of people who got a vaccination and then
went home and
had their event why are these two groups
so different
so
what i'm constantly told is that the
vare system
is
unreliable and therefore that the huge
spike in adverse events following the
covet vaccines is not meaningful
but nobody seems to know
what that implies they seem to think
that implies that these things are safe
which it doesn't at best it implies that
we don't know how safe they are and it
is odd that they suddenly decided that
it was unreliable this year
it was it was it was strangely reliable
through 2020 through you know or you
know 2019 let's say through flu season
pre-covered the vera system was
considered reliable and oddly enough
when
2021 came around and we rolled out the
kovic 19 vaccines it became abruptly
unreliable um i don't know how that
happened or to put it differently uh
previously it was regarded if anything
as uh needing to be multiplied by a
multiplying factor so if it was
unreliable in any way it was by uh under
reporting rather than by over reporting
now suddenly we're supposed to believe
it's vastly over reported and i don't
know why we should be so confident of
that right we can't possibly be
confident of that but i guess i would
say again
i don't want to give the benefit of the
doubt because i don't believe it is a
reasonable doubt but if we bend over
backwards
to
grant everything that those who claim
these vaccines are safe
uh want us to believe at best we've got
a system that doesn't tell us how safe
they are it certainly doesn't tell us
that there's no problem that they are
safe right and let me also add that the
pop-up you get on facebook or any of the
these other places will say and are
continuing to be monitored for safety so
it won't just say that they're safe
it'll say and they're being carefully
monitored and i'm going
where is this happening where is this
continuing monitoring happening if not
through theirs is there some secret
system that they're using to being
continually monitoring no obviously the
vare system was supposed to be that
system right and so that part of the
that part of it should be deleted in any
event if they're now going to say that
that system has no monitoring capability
because it's some wildly unreliable the
other place you could monitor it is you
could continue to monitor the level of
events in the control group of the
initial safety trial versus the
treatment group but they didn't allow
that either my understanding is that
they
treated everybody
after the short initial test period so
there is no remaining control group so
again we have a system that for whatever
reason
is incapable of delivering us a signal
that these vaccines are dangerous even
if they are and so what we are left with
is a world of anecdotes that we are told
we must ignore which epistemologically
does not make any sense
and
uh it must be driving you crazy as an
epistemologist to be
in the group that is uh held at the
level of anecdote and then
to watch the conversation continue as if
nothing abnormal is taking place
right and then um
when you would be willing to be studied
and you're not being contacted to be
studied i mean not just me but others
would make our
medical information if someone wanted to
do like a retrospective study or
something like that it's like fine you
know if you would like to turn us into
data we are only too happy to be turned
into data and and there's uh so far
quite a lack of interest in that
so to fill that in and i you know i
think most people probably will figure
it out on their own but were you to find
yourself in this group
you have taken a vaccine
something has happened to your life you
discover there are many others you don't
know whether you're stuck with these
symptoms permanently whether they will
clear up on their own whether you're
stuck with them except if a treatment is
found and hopefully it will be and so of
course you want to be studied the amount
of good that would come from
understanding what has happened to you
is potentially huge and the benefit of
it would go to you so
there's no it's there's no mystery that
there are lots of people waiting to have
somebody say all right i'm sick of being
an anecdote let's turn me into data
figure out what's going on so we can
help the others who have the same
condition right and yet
it doesn't happen
[Music]
you